I can't believe I'm finally going to
talk about this hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'm going to be going
where we really have not ventured before
we're gonna talk about How likely you
are to lose weight for good and what the
research says are the real keys to doing
it but first you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as we
will be discussing weight loss calories
numbers and obesity in detail so please
please skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you
are not already subscribed hit that
subscribe button and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen
also a big thank you to Eric Williamson
PhD and registered dietitian at unlocked
Fitness who helped consult on today's
video you can find some information
about his unique coaching program for
all of your Fitness and Nutrition goals
in the description below okay big breath
so you've probably heard the statistic
that 95 of diets fail I've probably said
this number before myself but it's a
number that I can imagine feels really
overwhelming and discouraging for a lot
of folks who are actively trying to lose
weight but what does this household
statistic even mean and is the reality
for hopeful dieters actually so dismal
well let's start with a little story
time shall we so I didn't actually know
this until we did this deep dive because
for a lot of us dietitians this number
has just become what we've heard
constantly over and over again and we
just accept as truth but that number can
actually be traced back to a study from
1959 where 100 people were given a
weight loss diet and success was defined
as a loss of 20 pounds or more in their
first visit to the research center they
are basically told how to maintain a
diet below 1500 calories and then sent
on their merry way
39 of the patients never returned to the
clinic for their scheduled follow-ups
and let's be real treat me like that I
probably would not have either and from
there we had 12 patients who lost more
than 20 pounds and just six of which who
maintained it a year later and if we
round that off nicely we have our sad
little 95 of diets fail stat now this
paper also reviewed some previous
studies that also tend to support the
suggestion that 95 of weight loss
interventions failed but these were all
pre-1959 where the approach was mainly
very low calorie diets prescribed with
very little guidance both during and
following the intervention in other
words this was a prime example of the
old adage they didn't fail at the diet
the diet failed them looking at this I
feel like it's comical that we expected
any of this to work even the study's
primary author himself was quoted in the
New York Times in 99 saying that was the
state of the art in 1959 I being sort of
surprised that people are still citing
it I know we do better these days I'll
say you know I am certainly not a fan of
most diets out there but it would be
unprofessional of me to subscribe to
this statistic today knowing that the
diet these poor participants were
expected to succeed at was truly the
pits so yeah let's agree that this study
isn't the best piece of research ever
done it's a miracle that they had as
much retention as they did and as the
author said these days we do better but
how much better are the results well a
lot of modern diets throw around their
own success statistics most of which
seem a lot more promising than that
original 95 of diets fail the challenge
is that a lot of privately funded
research for commercial diets tends not
to study or at least not report
long-term stats and that's likely
because if they did their numbers would
look far less enticing Noom for example
cites a success rate of 77 percent of
their participants being able to lose
weight with the app but after a year
they actually lost half of their study
participants and their data actually
shows that only one percent of people
who use NuMe were still using it after
six months and poor adherence and
follow-up is a general problem in diet
research with most studies looking at
diet and weight loss retention only up
to an average of 16 months most people
want to maintain their lower weight for
decades not months but still this is
pretty much the best that we got so what
does the more recent and arguably better
research in this area suggests is your
true chances of weight loss success well
the first question that we really need
to answer is what exactly do we mean by
success is just losing some amount of
weight a success what about weight loss
that doesn't improve our health is that
considered a success because Let Me Tell
You Folks most weight loss diets are
looking strictly at the number on the
scale so trying to answer the question
How likely are you to succeed on your
diet is really not a straightforward
question but to me weight loss is not
useful if it can't be maintained so to
get the best sense of longevity we need
to speak to the eight-year look ahead
trial unlike the diet from the 1950
study that we discussed the look-ahead
trials approach was pretty well
integrated multi-faceted evidence-based
and supportive it included one-on-one
support with health professionals
including dietitians nutrition
interventions that were tailored to the
individual a focus on developing
positive balanced behaviors
incorporation of other key weight loss
factors beyond diet like sleep and
exercise and most importantly continued
professional support after the program
for weight maintenance I would say this
is a pretty good template of what to
look for in a supportive weight
management program now we know from
other data that having long-term support
and follow-up is the key to improving
chances of weight maintenance and the
one-on-one professional support is also
particularly important from my
perspective to help to reduce the risk
of disordered eating and screen for
eating disorders which you would be
shocked to know that most diet programs
do not do new new
foreign
as I'm sure you can imagine there's a
strong correlation between disordered
eating and dieting and we aren't really
sure which comes first the chicken or
the egg but regardless dieting can
certainly reinforce problematic eating
behaviors and beliefs which is why
proper supervision is really key but
let's talk about what they found after a
solid eight years of intervention about
half of their
2570 participants kept off at least five
percent of their Baseline weight a
quarter kept off around 10 percent and
around 10 percent of people kept off at
least 15 percent some of you may look at
this graph and think wow like that's
impressive and others might feel very
discouraged thinking like oh what the
[ __ ] that's it one thing we can probably
all agree on is that it's far easier to
lose and maintain smaller amounts of
weight than larger amounts of weight due
to the physiological and psychological
adaptations to maintain what you may
have heard of as your set point weight
now despite what some of the weight loss
Bros on Tick Tock might tell you your
body's desire to keep you within a
certain weight range is a real thing in
fact I've got a whole blog post on the
phenomenon and different theories right
here but in short our bodies do prefer
to stay in a comfortable range and while
it may be easier to shift to the lower
end of that set point range it can be a
real fight to jump below your natural
threshold and stay there there are a lot
of compensatory mechanisms that make
significant and permanent weight loss a
struggle for most but the big three
physiological drivers are metabolism
activity and hunger so number one when
we diet and we lose weight our
metabolism slows down it happens most
studies estimate a five percent decline
which could mean needing let's say 50 to
150 fewer calories per day just to
maintain your new weight number two we
subconsciously just move less most of
this is in neat or non-exercise activity
thermogenesis so not necessarily less
time in the gym but rather things that
you don't even notice that you do so
research on this area suggests that
dieters burn about 35 percent or 350
calories less every day just by
subconsciously walking standing and
fidgeting less compared to similar folks
who have never lost weight so even
though the world is like really obsessed
with metabolism boosting and declines
when it comes to Weight Management this
unconscious movement actually plays a
much bigger role and that brings me to
number three hunger folks ghrelin is a
[ __ ]
research consistently shows that our
hunger hormones like graylin become
elevated Beyond Baseline in folks who
have lost weight so this is not just low
willpower but physiologically when your
body shrinks your appetite legitimately
grows and this isn't even speaking to
the psychological piece we know that
when you feel psychological deprivation
like denying yourself foods that you
really really love and crave you're more
likely to overeat them when you get the
rare chance you know it's the classic
last summer mentality or cheat day
situation that I talk about all the time
motivation also tends to wane over time
for obvious and understandable reasons
since fighting against all of these
normal healthy bodily processes gets
exhausting as again this is not just a
matter of poor willpower or your body
feeling you it's literally just trying
to keep you alive
ah ah staying alive staying alive
staying alive staying alive so yeah I'm
not gonna sugarcoat it permanent weight
loss is very very hard and it will be
disproportionately hard and possibly
completely improbable for some people
due to genetics demographics and
environmental factors like socioeconomic
status access and support as we've
discussed it's not impossible across the
board and it's likely possible for more
than five percent of the population as
we previously thought what I think is a
lot more useful than knowing your
specific chance of losing weight is
knowing the best way that you should try
to do it and we do have research to give
us some insight into what successful
dieters do so if we look at National
weight control Registries we can see
data from more than 10 000 people who
have lost more than 10 percent of their
body weight and kept it off most of
which is for more than 10 years that's
pretty impressive data I would say now
among the top reported behaviors that
have resulted in long-term weight loss
weren't keto or intermittent fasting
they were things like regular exercise
increased vegetable consumption ensuring
nutritious food options are easily
available to them like for example
keeping veggies and fruit in the house
for like a fast snack and maintaining
conscious awareness of their intake so
for example knowing how to read and
Compare food labels at the store and a
lot of the little things that dieters do
to lose weight will need to be
maintained in order to keep it off the
more weight that you lose the more you
need to keep doing because if you lost
weight doing keto and intermittent
fasting for example and then you start
eating carbs plus breakfast again you
are very likely going to gain that
weight right back thanks to all of those
physiological adaptations that we just
discussed we also have some insight into
to the psychological components of a
successful diet for weight loss and
weight loss maintenance mainly that a
flexible approach to eating is more
successful than a rigid one that cuts
out certain bad foods or signs other
obsessive rules as you all know if
you're a regular here at Abby's kitchen
that means that no food should be off
limits and each food has its place in
your diet depending on the context and
timing so for example a birthday party
might mean a slice of birthday cake
while not having it become like a
fixture of your daily evening routine
research also confirms that having an
internal locus of control and strong
self-efficacy where you feel in control
and confident in your way of eating can
also help to increase your chances of
long-term success essentially the more
confident you feel in your understanding
of what you need to do to maintain your
weight loss the better it can be a
complex learning process that goes far
beyond just like maintain a certain
calorie intake so this is just yet
another reason why we encourage working
with an experienced Rd bottom line folks
weight loss is hard and weight loss
maintenance is really really hard if
you've died down to 150 pounds you are
always going to have to put in more
effort to maintain that weight than
someone who was always 150 pounds
especially if you're at the bottom end
of your body's preferred weight range of
200. weight loss maintenance is also
going to be harder for some folks than
others thanks to the Natural
physiological and psychological
mechanisms that we just discussed along
with a slew of other genetic and
environmental barriers so please folks
give yourself some Grace if you're
struggling to lose weight and maintain
it this is never going to be just a
matter of a calorie deficit and a lot of
willpower this is not your body failing
you or that you need to try harder next
time so let's try to just appreciate
that our body is doing what it's meant
to do even if it's maybe not what we
want it to do so for more tips on some
gentle flexible suggestions for losing
weight you can check out my video right
here and again a big thank you to Eric
for his expertise on this topic
definitely check out his Link in the
description and give him a follow at
unlocked Fitness Nutrition if you're
looking for some 101 support and on that
note that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with any questions that you might
have subscribe to the channel and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]